please be with you welcome to the D show
another exciting episode now did you
know that this man that we're going to
be discussing today he is the man who is
rated the number one influential human
beings in history 1935 the Supreme Court
of America honored him as one of the
greatest law givers and so many others
great intellectuals great historians
people academics have praised him for
all of his wonderful accomplishments but
now there are also many people in his
name who do opposite to his teachings so
we want to find out how would he react
to those people now who insulted him who
belittled him who did all sorts of harm
physical and verbal and how we as
Muslims for the one that sold it dear to
our heart we don't worship Him as a god
but he was sent by God to deliver the
message of God just like Jesus Abraham
Moses and all the other messengers
calling people to worship the Creator
not the creation and he was the best
example for mankind that's right we're
going to be talking about his life and
his example and how we should emulate
him in the best of ways and how we
should react to some of these craziness
that's out there slandering him when we
come back here on the Deen show don't go
anywhere
this is the this is within you this is
the days of the theme you know this is
the welcome back to the usual peace be
with you uh Salam alaykoum when it comes
to learn more about the life how are you
doing share hum dil alhamdulillah thank
you for being with us here on the D show
well thank you for having me here
now we opened up many people don't know
they don't know about the greatest meant
when we say are we exaggerating now that
when we talk about Muhammad peace be
upon him I mean this doesn't take away
from Jesus Moses and all the other great
men who were messenger sent by God many
people don't know that he was ranked or
the most influential men in history and
all of these other fascinating wonderful
things that really soften the heart when
you learn about him
absolutely bismillah al-rahman al-rahim
well first of all a Lost Planet Allah
has sent him as Rahmatullah l-'alameen
mercy to all that exists and this title
was only given to Prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him obviously all the previous
prophets they came with a similar
message of worshipping of one God and
they're staying away from things that
are that exploit people in Justices
corruption to stay away from that and to
call towards the worship of one God so
he par excellance being the final of God
messenger to humanity the message he has
come with is just that message of the
worship the Creator not the creation now
someone says our brothers in humanity
who we want the best for we got love for
all of mankind as I was sharing this
message so our fellow Christians out
there said no no how you going to
compare Muhammad to Jesus when Jesus
said for God so loved the world whoever
believes in Him shall have eternal life
right and you don't have
this with with you have all this love
coming from Jesus we got all of this
this violence coming with Mohammed how
would you answer yeah because they don't
really know anybody who says that really
have not read even a page on the life of
Prophet Muhammad when you look back at
his life he suffered tremendously just
like Jesus peace be upon him he also
suffered tremendously and attempts were
made to assassinate them similarly in
the time of the Prophet SAW Selim
as this message of God is being
delivered to humanity there are many
people who become you know very much
against this message of peace this
message of justice this message of
harmony because it is true corruption
people get to do what they want to do
and how they want to do and so Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him went through
a lot of sacrifice a lot of moments when
people have even attempted to to kill
him groups as well as individuals and we
have seen his remarkable way of dealing
with them isn't it true that in your
scholar in Islam isn't it true and it's
not sugarcoating anything that if you
say look that I don't like Jesus let
alone I don't love him I don't believe
in him that is a Muslim you will go to
the Hellfire absolutely I mean Jesus is
part of our faith and I always tell our
Muslim our Christian brethren in faith
that apart from Christians Muslims hold
a very high status unbelief and love for
Jesus peace be upon him so without
respecting him without believing that he
is a Messenger of God we cannot be an
upright Muslim now if you contrast his
light Jesus peace be upon him before we
go to Muhammad peace and blessings be
upon him that when this day quote this
verse for God so loved the world that he
said we believe that Jesus was sent can
we interpret this that for God so loved
the world that he sent prophets and
messengers to guide humanity with yeah
absolutely because in our scriptures
Allah says it very clearly in accra
and bismillahi r-rahmani r-rahim allahu
w'allahu I had Allah who saw my de
l'etoile amulet well a miracle oh who
Khufu and I had and this short chapter
is entitled the chapter of the class or
sincerity that say he allah is one he is
the absolute he begets not nor is He
begotten and nothing is comparable unto
Allah so this was when some people asked
the Prophet SAW seller what is the
genealogy of of Allah that Allah has
children because in that time in the
time of the Prophet peace be upon him
they Quraysh used to say the angels were
the daughters of Allah so there were
people who were placing daughters to
Allah and again Allah you know address
that in Quran and in this particular
surah it tells you that Allah is unique
he has no son he has no daughter he is
the creator and everything else is
creation including Jesus peace be upon
him he's a created being and so we
respect that we respect that he is a
Messenger of God
he came with the truth he came and
established the truth and so Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him was the final
Messenger of God that he came with that
final message to humanity what about the
person says what about all this violence
every time I turn on CNN there's some
Muslim out there and he's representing
Muhammad allegedly and now all of this
negative stereotype has been associated
it's not yes a lot of things that we see
in the name of Islam actually in fact
are something else coated with the name
of Islam because if we look back at the
life of Prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him we will see that there is no there
many times people let us take for
example America khattab radhi'allahu Han
but before he became a Muslim he was on
the verge of he was on his way to kill
the prophets of Allah and on his way he
met this other companion who was hiding
his Islam his name was nine
and he said that okay I where you going
Omari said I'm going to finish off this
man once and for all and he meant
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him and
so after that know I'm said trying to
side track him not to go there he said
why don't you go and take care of your
sister and your brother they have become
Muslim and we know this story that when
he went there and he saw passages of the
Quran so like many people they have not
seen the Quran for many people's limbs
they have not read the life of the
Prophet SAS Allah so they pick up verses
they pick up situations they have their
own agenda tie all together they do this
violence and Islam get all the blame so
there has nothing to do you got a judge
Islam but actions max by not the actions
of Muslims but by the actual text and we
have to interpret it not according to
our desires absolutely the texts are
within a context the text has historical
context it has over the ages great
scholars have given interpretations to
them and none of these have called for
violence or to use violent means as a
way of establishing our faith charlie
help woman ask you about this I'm going
to ask you about the hysteria usually
when this messenger who we love dearly
he's insulted how we should react to it
yeah more of this here the Deen show
don't go anywhere
please subscribe to the DCO follow us on
our official Facebook and Twitter pages
in the links below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below
welcome back to the D show we are
talking about the most influential man
in history and this is the greatest man
to ever walk the earth now this has been
stated in the book written by Michael H
Hart and many others we talked about
academics historians who really
sincerely looked at his life and they
had the utmost wonderful things to say
about him but now you had mentioned that
most Muslims they don't even read or
study his serie yesterday so can you
elaborate on that when you're ignorant
now the emotions take charge so now you
can't defend him in
an academic in a polite way you end up
doing more harm harm and emotionally and
that is exactly what is happening and I
think some people who study the Muslim
world by and large their behavior they
see that you say something and there is
no intellectual discussion on that there
is a lot of emotional outbursts that go
in contrary to what Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him has brought and so
when situations such as Charlie Hebdo
when he you know did this cartoon and
the satire about the Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him that should be a an
opportunity for the Muslim world to
become engage in a dialogue and to let
the world know who is Muhammad peace be
upon him obviously we are all heard
intellectual or non intellectual anybody
who insults your Creator
anybody who insults a prophet of God
even if they insult Jesus peace be upon
him we feel hurt even they insult Moses
peace be upon him we feel hard they
insult Muhammad peace be upon him we
feel hard this is a believer must not
feel joy when somebody it solves any of
the prophets of Allah let alone the best
of all the human being Muhammad peace be
upon him
so this 1.8 billion Muslims you feel
hurt when this happens but I see it and
I think there is enough evidence from
the serie of the Prophet SAW similar
that when people come to harm him he
took the opportunity to engage them in
the message not in their action and so
this opportunity to engage in the
message is what we must do and so for
example when Omar eben Wahab he left
Makkah and he a Safwan who were not yet
Muslims at that time this was just after
the Battle of Badr they had a private
conversation and Omar said to Safwan you
know what if I had the means of taking
care of my dad and my raising my
children you know I would have left them
behind and I would have gone and killed
Muhammad peace be upon him Safwan who
was a rich guy at that time said look
don't worry I'll take care of your debt
take care of adjourn you go and do what
you have to do and so the two of them
alone knew this plot he did not even
tell his wife all he said you're gonna
hear big news this is a paid assertion
now this is a paid assassin and he knew
that he was going to get killed by doing
that because he's now going to medina
where the profit is now the leader so
you're doing a an assassination to the
leader of you know a people and so he
went there and as soon as the prophet
saw sell him saw him he said why why
have you come over he said well you know
I come here because my son is a prisoner
of war I've come to ransom him and Allah
had revealed to him while Omar was on
his way that he is coming to kill you
and he has a sword poison sword so even
if it were to touch the professor cell
and he would have died if not from the
womb but from the poison and so the
Prophet peace be upon him said so what
about the sword so he said oh this sword
you know and then there was any good and
better so prophet system said tell me
why have you come
you have come because you and stuff one
had a discussion at the Kaaba that you
were going to come and kill me and he's
going to take care of you and your
family and your debts and so forth and
right away he said I have to testify
that no one is worth the abortion but
Allah and that you are the Messenger of
Allah nobody knew that not even my wife
knew that and this is the sword o
prophet of Allah I have come to kill you
now under any law of modern time whether
it is Geneva Convention or or or Oslo
convention or the law of the land
anybody who goes with the intention with
the tool with the purpose of assassins
assassinating the leader or the
president of a country even if you were
to give him the death penalty you would
have been justified but profitsystem did
not give him the death penalty he give
him what will liberate him in this world
and the hereafter he give him Islam
there are so many examples of that under
the example o example food Allah even
Omar this was another one he was going
this is after Fatah Makkah which after
gaining victory now he was going when
the profitsystem was going along the
Kaaba doing Tawaf around the Kaaba
he was going to plunge a dagger behind
him from behind him and he knew
obviously I'm going to be killed and
when he was near to reach a professor
professorson turned on and said are you
full Allah said yes nonprofit system
just put his hand and said me Allah may
Allah bring Islam to your heart so what
I am seeing here is that people and
nations and tribes all those who went to
kill the prophets of Salaam he gave them
what was better for them he gave them
Islam he did not emotionally said ok
this man is coming to kill me he is you
know
evil let's get rid of him no he gave
them the message of Islam the message of
peace what do you say to our brothers
and humanity when they turn on a TV and
again they see all of this you know a
stereo revolved around Islam and they
say look you know they see Isis being
portrayed 24/7 on the TV like it's
representing the majority of Muslim so
they think they say look you guys are
the silent minority they are the the the
vast majority you know they flip it
around and now they think that that's
representation of Islam no absolutely
not
as a matter of fact we have been saying
from the very beginning whether
something happened to the Prophet or not
whether a violence takes place or not we
are saying that Islam is not a violent
religion so when violence comes on we
are saying that look back at these
people they are doing something which is
not Islamic which is not which does not
represent the vast majority of Muslims
this is a minority of a minority
unfortunately these are the people who
get the wide publicizing and so the
world sees them they don't see the vast
majority who are struggling to contract
this kind of violent expression or
manifestation of or in the name of Islam
so for for a person who sees how would
you now your spiritual leader in the
community when someone does see because
holding a balance when you see a lot of
injustice is we would say that Muslims
are the most oppressed people now in the
world today can you can we can we
rightfully say that absolutely I mean if
you look back at all the Muslim the wars
in the Muslim country and leaders and so
forth of pressure that go
upon them yes there but again it does
not call for for any violent means of
changing what could have been more
oppressive which society could have been
more unjust and oppressive than the
Meccan Society for which the professor
Salem had come and thirteen years he
spent with them and he never waged any
war against them and when he came to
Medina he did not
most of these battles that that were
fought were instigated by the mackins
themself it was not that okay let's go
and fight them now it is they did not
stop coming after them even after
expelling them from Makkah we're going
to take a break and we're going to talk
more about the proper channels to take
to express some of your emotions when we
come back here on a day show don't go
anywhere please subscribe to the DCO
follow us on our official Facebook and
Twitter pages in the links below
please also help support the V show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the D show so before I went to
break we want to break the right course
of action because it's natural now you
see a lot of the oppression you see a
lot of your brothers I mean we are
brothers in humanity but those also to
submit to the credit after creation
those who follow the way of jesus knows
abraham who are muslims we now see them
suffering in other parts of the world
and some of the young naive you know
they see this and they want to they
think that now i'm going to go and do
some good i'm going to go fly across the
land and you know get in some some some
war over there and whatnot and instead
of taking some proper channels what
course of action because here obviously
you have the right to speak you know to
go ahead and to voice your concern to
take you know the proper means tell us
what are some of those proper means the
proper course of action
besides violent actions and you know
hurting innocent men women and children
which islam as opposed to what proper
course of action could we take yes well
i would i would say first and foremost
religious leaders in America and around
the world they need to give the right
message to the younger generation and
that message is that it's a message of
engagement using the
opportunity to engage in dialogue in
talking to people as the prophecies and
have engaged in dialogue in individuals
in whole tribes and a whole nation so we
are not we have cut off this process of
presenting Islam in an intellectual and
in a peaceful way so scholars need to
give that message it's not a message of
war it's not the message of violence
it's not a message of treachery and let
alone these young people who whose you
know have passion for whatever they
think they can now change the world
without them without any motive when you
are teenage years you feel like you can
conquer the world I mean we've all
passed through that at one point or
another whether you think you look the
best in the whole village you're the
best you're the most macho guy whatever
it is you always felt that the whole
world is you can you can actually change
this whole world and so that energy
needs to be channeled and I'll give you
a good example when also the conquest of
Makkah bilal radhi'allahu and began
obviously he was chosen by the Prophet
SAS and to stand on the Kaabah and to
give the first a van and there were some
young men who start juggling is it who
you know look he is giving them
basically like as if an Abyssinian of
former Abyssinian slave cannot have that
position and so this message came to the
professor Selim and he called these
young men and said to one of them
you said so so so well they were afraid
they said yes we said so he said do you
have a good voice let me hear your voice
and he taught him the event and then he
said ok now you go and call the event so
turning that energy into something that
is positive that's something that will
benefit that is what our it is our huge
need to do secondly our youths need to
take time off and to study the serie
from the original sources
yes they're translated books they're
books in English and I'm sure several
languages you have Authentics books of
the biography of the Prophet SAW Selim
they need to study every aspect of that
thirdly I think parents also need to sit
for children and to tell if they are
inclined into any form of extreme
thoughts extreme belief extreme actions
they need to sit with them and say this
is not the way forward rather this is
counter productive or counter islam this
is against Islamic teachings so from the
from the pulpit of the preachers to the
home to the child then these things are
to be channeled in the positive in the
right direction and when we see violent
things we have equally we have to speak
out against them so that they would see
that this is not normal and this is not
correct so tell us I want to just focus
on this for a minute
when we see the treaty of hudaibiya the
Muslims were about 1400 is this correct
yes when the peace now treaty was signed
how much time was it from there until
the conquest of Mecca and we see a jump
a dramatic jump from 1400 to plus 10,000
is this where the dowel was open that
you can go ahead and share this message
yes exactly so the the treaty of
hudaibiya to the conquest of Makkah
maybe we are talking about less than two
years less than two years Islam
multiplied tenfold or more not to the
sword now not two so this is time that's
dhawan this is Dawa because all that for
forged our full force now sharing and
this is the first time if you look back
at the seer of the prophecies Selim if
you talk about freedom this will be that
moment of freedom because all the other
episode in his life anything anytime he
went to another tribe it was the Quraysh
that came and said no you can't do this
no this is our tribe this out so it was
always something stopping them so within
two years of freedom no fighting is not
multiplied tenfold so then the question
is
that they any battle help to promote
Islam I mean it was more in defense yes
but if you really want to promote this
message of peace we have to take the
path that where there is no violence
there is no Treasury there is no
extremism with the freedom to express
yourself and to invite humanity to this
religion of peace I think that is what I
would my message to our youth now tell
us a little bit your organization also
many people they see this word hear this
word Sharia you're actually the chairman
of the Sharia Committee on acknow tell
us what does word means and what a
little bit about your information your
organization and what you do in it next
we got one minute left yes so Sharia we
have had as a matter fact two three
years ago we've had a complete
Convention on the theme understanding
freedom of religion understanding Sharia
so Sharia is basically the way that God
so intent for the human being to live
his life through that divine guidance
this year our convention ignoramus
convention is in May in the Memorial
weekend in Baltimore and we are going to
Baltimore and you know Baltimore right
now is going through this phase of again
challenging injustice but you cannot do
another injustice while removing an
injustice so it will be very good that
we're going to see what plays out in
another three weeks and our theme of
this convention is simply Muhammad peace
be upon him and we think it is not we
don't wait for something to happen as
Muslims it is our responsibility to
invite people to the message of Muhammad
peace be upon him and to know who is
this person let alone when something
happens like from January to now or from
last year to now yes this is the
opportunity that we have again
intellectually to dialogue and to
present Muhammad peace be upon him as he
ought to be presented a man of peace and
the most influential human being that
ever
on the face of this earth thank you so
much we started with that piece went
with the piece and inshallah God willing
I'll see you again sometime soon on the
Deen show so I'm like wanna come see you
and thank you so much for tuning in
sure yeah you heard this word and you
know that Jesus peace be upon them Moses
they were practicing Sharia this is
divine guidance the ten commands that's
Shariah now you hear some of these words
you know an Arabic but Jesus spoke
Aramaic that's right they didn't speak
English so now but when you get a
translator you're like okay that makes
sense and for all those out there that
now they just go off emotion now we as
Muslims we have to do things the proper
way take the right course of action
we heard some wonderful examples from
our guest today so get informed about
the greatest man who ever walked the
earth and he was sent for you as a mercy
to mankind read about him look at the
message that he brought I guarantee you
it will resonate with your heart but put
all of his prejudice all of these
negative emotions to the side and
realize there is a purpose to life and
he's delivering it that's right
from the one who created life the crater
that happens in earth the one that Jesus
called you to worship Jesus never said
worship himself or anything in creation
but he came with the same message as all
the prophets and mohammed just being the
last of them get to know this man and
tune in every week to the deen show
subscribe if you haven't already
now you can you follow us on instagram
twitter keep up what's up with us we'll
see you next time peace be with you
sound like please subscribe to the d
show follow us on our official Facebook
and Twitter pages in the links below
please also help support the V show by
making a donation in the link below